how did we fall asleep during
interdimensional cable what the hell
summer all right Morty this noise let's
get out of here and go on a classic Rick
and Morty adventure Yeah right Rick come
on win no wonder you're constantly
fighting with each other behind schedule
what nothing hey everybody knew Morty's
mind-blower is probably one of the best
episodes of the season I love the way
that they make fun of themselves they
make fun of youtubers save it for
YouTube so let's just go through all the
Easter eggs and there is a new round of
that merch giveaway all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber leave a
comment on this video I'll name a new
winner at the end of this so starting
with them running through Morpheus as
Dream Land at the beginning of the
episode which is basically this giant 3d
MC Escher building it's a dark tower
Stephen King reference but it has Neil
Gaiman's Sandman who's running after
them while they're holding the truth
turtle so a lot of you Stephen King fans
have been messaging me asking me if the
turtle is actually a reference to
Stephen King's turtle who's like this
giant cosmic being and I think that's
what they were going for if you haven't
read the books the turtle is the
guardian of one of these cosmic beams
but he exists outside of the normal
universe he's so powerful that they say
that he actually got a stomach ache at
the beginning of creation and vomited up
the normal universe that's how big of a
concept he is there's this really cool
quote about him it says see the turtle
of enormous girth on his shell he holds
the earth his thought is slow but always
kind he holds us all within his mind so
you can see how they sort of used that
metaphor to give Morty the entire truth
the universal truth so a lot of you in
my timeline were wondering if we were
seeing a version of the origin story for
evil Morty before the big turn where
he's like I'm gonna kill myself I can't
take this all if they had have done that
part at the end I would have said yeah
totally we're seeing a version of evil
Morty being born here but it does lend
some credence to the idea that evil
Morty is a Morty who hasn't had his
memories extracted by whoever his first
Rick was whether it's our rig or whether
it was someone else I think that our
Rick does have a special
connection with them that we just
haven't learned yet but one of the
memory flashes actually did go back to
his 13th birthday and people keep
quoting Justin roiland is saying that
Rick didn't come back till Morty was 14
so they're actually pushing the timeline
further and further back on Rick and
Morty in this but for a couple minutes
in the episode Morty turns into bran
Stark he holds everything in his head
and just starts to go crazy but a lot of
you were wondering if this is bill
cipher like the Eye of Providence that's
sitting in the statue of the truth
turtle in the background here alex
hirsch actually posted these funny
tweets so per his explanation this is
not bill cipher because he's not wearing
a top hat but there was another gravity
falls Easter Egg because one of the
vials reads Stanford has in Stanford
Pines we actually found out the color
scheme but they didn't explain every
single color the greens I don't think we
ever found out what they were about but
the Blues were when Morty did something
bad the Reds were when Rick did
something bad the purple was when his
family did something bad and then we
never really get clarity on the yellow
or the green ones but I think they're
just going for a Pixar inside out thing
where you have the different emotions
that are different colors but like Rick
says don't read into it Morty I don't
color code my memories but he tends to
lie a lot about that but the way he
named them was pretty funny too like one
of them is named virginity so there are
a couple legit names like Dingle farts
that was the one where he was jacking
the alien off so not all them had
complete nonsense names but there was
the one that was in a mall gyum of a
bunch of different memories and he even
breaks the fourth wall again after the
menagerie one where Morty's like how
come I saw the other people's memories
and Rick's like I had to add some extra
context to make the memories play a
little bit better so he's talking to us
the audience in order to make the scenes
play better you need more context for
the characters but there were a crazy
number of Easter eggs throughout the
vignettes so you sort of ease in from
the more straight-up memories where
Morty does something bad to the really
crazy montage at the very end so it
starts out with more of a straight-up
rear-window Alfred Hitchcock story where
he accidentally gets somebody to commit
suicide because of a smudge on the lens
interesting thing to note summer seemed
crazy smart in this episode one she's
been through this several times so it's
totally casual for her to clean up their
mess at the end but it
the beginning of this first memory she
knows instantly that it's a smudge it's
probably a smudge and Morty just refuses
to believe that until the end of the
story so the other big fourth wall break
is when rick is explaining why they
can't give the memories special names
because we're not doing a simpsons
halloween special that's like the Adult
Swim executive telling them that they
can't name this exactly like you would
do a Simpsons Halloween special because
we don't want to get sued by Fox so most
of you probably picked up on the
menagerie Easter eggs the menagerie is a
Star Trek episode from the original
series where Christopher Pike and
another person get captured by the two
oceans that look like this crazy veiny
alien that just collects other creatures
trying to make them mate because they've
lost the ability so it's a creepy
premise but it's an amazing Star Trek
story but you spot a couple of other
creatures from previously in the series
there's a female cos or peon right
across from them and there's a couple of
meeseeks I couldn't see all the cells so
there might be some more familiar aliens
in the background here but their escape
is basically a parody of the contact
movie with Jodie Foster where they send
them instructions oh it's a code they
want us to come find them so Rick tricks
her in they swap places and come back so
presumably that Jodie Foster character
and that other guy are still stuck in
there at the mercy of the two oceans the
really cool thing about the Floop Floop
Ian's memory is that this is actually
the omae's winner from last year doing
the voice for this so it's just a
totally normal person that won an omae's
charity contest and got to voice this
character we learned that Beth loves
summer more than Morty which is kind of
a bummer Bebo is just a tonton joke from
Empire Strikes Back
captain Skye I think was a reference to
Captain Skyhawk which was a classic NES
invasion game from back in the 80s then
there's a little bit of a continuity
error when they start going at each
other and they break all the vials Rick
picks up a purple one walks into the
next frame and is holding a blue one
there were a crazy number of men and
black references Rick thinks the movies
were joyless trash but the mind eraser
is something from the men and black
movies that they use a lot for comedy
and when Morty makes the pederast
reference it's just a funny twist on the
dock Marty relationship from Back to the
Future like if you saw a teenage boy
spending lots of
I'm up at the weird mansion of a notable
crazy person you would probably think
that he was a weirdo too but one of my
favorites was Morty making the YouTube
joke save it for YouTube Rick he's
talking about his men in black to rant
he's just making fun of YouTube rant
videos so they were making fun of
youtubers but they also made fun of
themselves at the end of the episode
which was probably one of the best ones
- if you remember last year there was an
article going around where somebody had
misquoted Dan Harmon and then a bunch of
other people started misquoting him
saying that season three had been
delayed because they've been fighting
inside the writers room so that's what
summers making fun of when she Riley
says you fight so much no wonder you're
so far behind schedule she's basically
talking about the writers and of course
that was all false - Dan Harmon came out
then and clarified his statements he's
like no no no we all love each other we
just took way too long riding the season
I think the level memory is one of the
few times we see shirtless Rick in
addition to the unity episode and then
one of the big mind blowers is that we
learned they had to jump to another
reality again meaning that we don't know
which reality is the one that they're in
in the show right now he directly
references a line of dialogue from the
Cronenberg episode you know I said we
can only do that a couple of times
we're over here the answer is don't
think about it it's not like we could do
this every week anyways we get three or
four more of these tops but there are a
couple minor continuity errors because
of the memories that they still have
with them at the end of the episode like
you look at the Jerry box and you see
the apples from M night Shyamalan 'z
meaning that a lot of these memories
were taken out before Cronenberg world
so they should have jumped to another
reality so they shouldn't have any of
these memories with them so I think the
idea is that the episode is actually
taking place in present-day
but here check this out this is their
whiteboard for all the ideas they had
for all these separate bin yets
you can see the ones that didn't make it
so if you were confused about where in
the time line this episode is supposed
to fit just assume it's in present day
and there were a couple of errors but
like I said we see Morty's 13th birthday
the reason it's a mind-blower is because
we think that he didn't meet c-137 Rick
until he was 14 so the timeline is just
getting
pushed earlier we see him accidentally
killing Santa somehow he gets engaged to
mr. poopy butthole so he also comes back
I know people like where's mr. poopy
butthole
we see a doll version of Morty being
juggled by Rick so he turned him into a
doll so he could pull him apart like an
action figure
then juggle him we see a Ghostbusters
memory he gets his head stuck on
snuffles body when summer fixes them it
turns on interdimensional Cable for them
it's a version of house hunters where
they're literally hunting houses like
you actually see the houses bleed after
they shoot them and then everybody
picked up on the ET reference for
Jerry's mind blowers it's a good PSA for
not leaving your children in hot cars
with the windows rolled up or your
animals and I love the fact that Jerry's
mind blowers are all on VHS tapes but I
think that's just a continuation of the
ET reference because that's a classic
80s movie so I think they were just
going with that motif for Jerry but let
me know in the comments have you spotted
any other references that I didn't
mention in the video my next Rick and
Morty video will be for episode 9 I'll
do a trailer video for that tomorrow and
congratulations to Alberto Nava you're
the latest merch giveaway winner please
private message me on the back end of my
channel so I can get your contact
details I'll name a new winner when I
post new Rick and Morty so click here
for all my other Rick and Morty videos
and you can click here for brand new
flash season 4 thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome see you
guys tonight
[Music]
[Applause]